being part of the global Scholars
Program has led me to interact with
fellows from all of the different
programs that includes microbiologist
that includes physicists who study
cosmology it includes sociologists who
study successful societies and from them
I've learned to take my research in may
be more ambitious directions but also to
think more of sort of the end societal
impact of what we're working on in the
lab I'm Joel Zilber Berg I was among the
first cohort of CFR as really global
scholars I'm currently Associate Fellow
of learning and machines and brains at
CFR I used to do my best thinking in
very solitary settings so I would be out
running or I'd be climbing in the
mountains or I'd be out sailing these
days I find I do my best thinking at CFR
meetings where I can talk with some of
the smartest people in the field
exchange ideas and that sort of
back-and-forth really builds on itself
and leads to better ideas than I would
come up with myself the biggest benefit
to me has been really connecting with
some of the smartest people in the world
to work together on science
[Music]